this video is sponsored by the book
summary app blinkist use the link in the
description and you'll receive one free
week and 25 off an annual premium
membership
Enlightenment is man's emergence from a
self-imposed immaturity immaturity is
the inability to use one's understanding
without guidance from another
Emmanuel Kant
born into an era of newly emerging
scientific understanding and individual
autonomy going on to play a crucial role
in the intellectual maturation of the
modern world and synthesizing new
understandings of human knowledge and
morality 18th century German philosopher
Emmanuel Kant is one of the most
consequential thinkers of modern history
Kant was born in 1724 in what was at the
time koenigsberg East Prussia what is
now Kalin and grad Russia he was born
into a very modest strict religious
family the fourth oldest of nine
children in young adulthood Kant
attended the University of kernersburg
where he soon became interested in the
Natural Sciences mathematics and
philosophy as his exposure to the recent
achievements of the Scientific
Revolution and Enlightenment
increasingly revealed to him the
emerging power of human reason and
independent thinking cop became critical
of his religious upbringing and
religious and political Authority in
general he observed the modern world
shifting alongside him away from Blind
Faith in religious and political
Authority and into secular independent
rational thinking
however Kant having seen and understood
the value of religion in the lives of
the people he had known and having
appreciated and respected how it
promoted ethical behavior and Good
Conduct he worried about the
consequences of humanity shifting away
from it Khan saw Humanity at a juncture
in which it was now mature enough to
leave home but not mature enough to know
how to live well on its own
during and following his education Kant
published many Works dealing with topics
related to metaphysics ethics
epistemology politics and Aesthetics
focusing his life's work on helping
facilitate the Western world's
successful transition into a new
enlightened age
in his Masterwork critique of pure
reason as well as throughout several of
his other works Kant attempted to do
this by examining current conceptions of
knowledge and reality synthesizing new
models of understanding and defining
reason as the ultimate source of good
Contra our age is the age of criticism
to which everything must be subjected
the sacredness of religion and the
authority of legislation are by many
regarded as grounds of exemption from
the examination of this tribunal but if
they are Exempted they become the
subjects of just suspicion and cannot
lay claim to sincere respect which
reason Accords only to that which has
stood the test of a free and public
examination
ultimately Khan's work attempted to
provide a framework for understanding
how we come to understand the world and
how and why we ought to behave in a
certain way in relation to it put
differently he sought to answer how we
take in the chaos of the natural world
distill it within us into order into
meaning and into ethical Behavior
Kant was not trying to destroy what
religion had historically provided but
rather he sought to augment and
replenish it for the conditions of the
Modern Age
in critique of pure reason Kant
discusses the process through which he
believes we come to acquire knowledge at
the time there were two primary schools
of thought empiricism and rationalism
and pierces argued that all knowledge is
derived from our sense experiences
rationalists argue that knowledge is
chiefly arrived at through reason Kant
however found himself somewhere in
between the two believing that knowledge
is derived from a particular combination
of our sense experiences and our faculty
for reason all facilitated by a
framework of a priori conditions he
famously wrote thoughts without content
are empty intuitions without concepts
are blind
in other words we need input data to
process but we also need a priori
conditions to process that data in order
to Output any meaning when referring to
a priori conditions here this simply
means something that is acquired
independently of experience in relation
to the mind and knowledge quantifying
these as space time reason and
self-consciousness we need space and
time to discern features of external
experiences we need reason to process
experiences into representations or
ideas and we need consistent
self-consciousness or identity in order
to unify the process from a fixed
position these all must exist first
before experience or observation for
there to be any experiences or
observations at all
Kant writes self-consciousness does not
yet come about by my accompanying each
representation with Consciousness but
rather by my adding one representation
to the other and being conscious of
their synthesis therefore it is only
because I can combine a manifold of
given representations in one
Consciousness that it is possible for me
to represent the identity of the
Consciousness in these representations
ultimately Kant arrives at a sort of
synthesis of empiricism and rationalism
in which a certain limited kind of
knowledge about the world can be
attained uniquely through human reason
Kant wrote all our knowledge begins with
the senses proceeds then to the
understanding and ends with reason there
is nothing higher than reason
as a result of this can't believe that
knowledge about how we ought to act in
the world also comes from reason to be
moral as a rational being for Kant is to
act rationally
Khan centers entire ethical theory on
perhaps one of his most famous
philosophical Concepts the categorical
imperative
in its original formulation Kant
describes it with the following Act only
according to that Maxim whereby you can
at the same time will that it should
become a universal law
in other words if you would not will
everyone else to do the same thing
you're doing it is an unethical act we
can determine this by asking ourselves
if the whole world committed the ACT
would the world no longer function or at
the very least be worse for you if yes
to act in such a way you are
contradicting and harming yourself for
example if everyone committed theft you
would become a victim of theft and the
world will become dysfunctional thus no
rational person could see it right to
steal and to act otherwise breaks moral
law like breaking the laws of
mathematics
all of this of course is a sort of
formal reconstruction of the golden rule
to unto others as you would have them do
unto you
Kant attempts to take this further
however by grounding it in a secular
philosophical system that showcases
essentially that being immoral does not
make rational sense and that
determinations of what is moral can be
concluded from reason alone
of course all this leads to some
potential problems what happens when the
Apparently more rational thing to do
goes against categorical imperatives
what happens when someone can cause more
harm or allow more harm by strictly
abiding by rigid moral principles what
if for example you stole a weapon from
someone to prevent them from harming a
group of people whom they were about to
attack with it is this immoral simply
because you broke the moral principle of
not stealing is it not more rational
though to steal the weapon than to
commit rigidly to the moral principle of
never stealing people who might follow
the ethical Theory known as
utilitarianism would argue that it is
more rational and moral to steal the
weapon making moral laws flexible to
situations moreover in a much broader
sense what are moral determinations
objectively even based on using reason
human Prosperity but is not human
Prosperity subjective how can we base an
objective ethical system in something
that is entirely dependent on human
subjectivity are we even truly rational
beings how can we ground our process of
thinking in something outside our
process of thinking for what reason do
we have other than reason itself to
follow reason reason seems like the
highest order of cognition of
understanding but is that sufficiently
grounded in anything objective in
anything fixed or rigid reason itself
seems to be only defensible through
circular reasoning
ultimately although Kant got some things
wrong and left some things unresolved he
got some crucial things right and
perhaps more importantly he helped
reveal new problems in need of resolving
and getting right he directly inspired
subsequent revolutionary thinkers like
Hegel schopenhauer Nietzsche Freud
wittenstein and so many more influencing
virtually all of Western thinking in
general still to this day he helped lead
and contribute to Mankind's courageous
still occurring step out from the
shelter of its Youth and into the world
as thinking things in Desperate search
for a new better independent condition
of Life a new chapter a new place to
call home
wherever it comes from whatever it is we
have seemingly all been given something
that compels us to understand to
organize to live well and to find
reasons to treat others with kindness so
as to allow them to do the same
throughout history we have tried so many
times in so many ways whether through
the nurturing of kinship and primitive
times through religions through reason
through science through it all we have
yet to fully understand where morality
comes from if it is objective or real
outside of us and how to define and
explain it if it is but yet in every age
and every day though messy and deeply
flawed somehow the world continues to
function and every day the vast majority
of us attempt to treat those we
encounter those we know those we love
with kindness
and perhaps that's real enough
and the words of Kant two things fill my
mind with ever increasing wonder and awe
the more often and the more intensely
the reflection dwells on them The Starry
heavens above me and the moral law
Within Me
[Music]
this video is sponsored by blinkist
Garrett wants to explore philosophy and
science more in his free time he's
always enjoyed these subjects but
general education never really made it
enjoyable or accessible to him now in
early adulthood he's begun trying on his
own picking out and reading all sorts of
books both Classics and modern the
problem is Garrett continually finds
himself reading material that he
struggles with understanding or ends up
not even really being that interested in
after investing hours into it one day
however everything changed Garrett was
introduced to an app called blinkist
which breaks down over 5 500 non-fiction
books into around 15-minute explainers
that can be both read and listened to
even while offline this suddenly allowed
Garrett to peruse hundreds of books in a
tiny fraction of the time now that he
could easily sift through these books he
was able to easily discover new insights
decide which books he wanted to read the
complete versions of and he could lean
on blinkus to help clarify and form
Frameworks around his reading while he
was reading meta citations on first
Philosophy by Rene descarte Garrett used
blinkus to help him Prime and refresh
his understanding about Descartes
ontological argument and theory of
substance dualism in which he believed
that the mind was separate from the body
all making the otherwise somewhat
difficult read actually comprehensive
and memorable Garrett shared blankets
with several of his friends all of which
had different interests but all found
tons of titles that they liked across
blinkist's 27 different categories
quietly Garrett shared a free blinkist
account that he got through blinker's
premium's feature blinkus connect with
his best friend Nathan
if you're interested in developing or
enhancing your reading habits as well
you can use the link in the description
or scan the QR code on the screen and
you'll receive two memberships to
blankets for the price of one a seven
day free trial and 25 off blank is
premium
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching in general and see you
next video
foreign